okay I get it to an extent because I
love and I talked about this with a
friend the other day I happen to love
and I don't really admit this often or
or or talk about this because people
might take it the wrong way and it's not
my fault I happen to really enjoy
funerals I love funerals
I love the wake I love the burial I love
the drive to the funeral everything
about a fuer I love seeing people you
haven't seen in a while but in a space
where you know you don't have to keep up
it's weird to exchange numbers nobody's
serious
nobody's gonna follow up with each other
in a week and go hey we saw each other
at the funeral you'd be insane if you
did that you'd be like what so if you
even reconnect at a funeral it's so
brief it's so surface it's so shallow
it's so nice it's so nice a have you
been and I good I like to cry I like to
be sad and think about my own mortality
and feel bad for other PI like to look
at other people that have lost a loved
one and feel bad for them and sometimes
it's nice when it's an older person who
we could all say what's a life
well-lived but sometimes it's nice when
it's someone younger sometimes it's nice
when it's somebody it was unexpected or
someone and we all have to really
reflect on what it means cuz the older
people you don't have to reflect on what
it means as much you get it they lived a
good life but sometimes it's got to be
dark and real tragic and they've got to
be young it's got to be young to really
get to cry on and get the purge you got
a purge you got a question what is life
why are we here am I on the right track
these are very important things la they
have silent retreats and yoga in the
Northeast we had funerals people would
just die and you would go I love I love
the meal have you ever had a funeral
meal will you go out afterwards and
everybody's eating and you're relaxing
it's kind of fun again it's kind of nice
again yes we buried someone and they're
not here but that means more shrimp
cocktail for us we're
here we're alive no disrespect car Ruis
a great man would love this attitude
passed away at forty four I feel very
bad man was he [ __ ] funnier than
comedians and I know that doesn't say
much but god this is [ __ ] funny was
it we guy fieri loved him he was a chef
he opened the great restaurant in New
York or la Cubana the guy was hitting he
texted me a photo on Twitter that made
me laugh harder and some anything else
I'm gonna show it to Ben right now dude
and this is it and familiarize yourself
with the great call Ruiz if you have it
because I'm telling you right now this
guy everybody loved him Sherrod small
you know Opie and Anthony Vic n Lee all
these comics really love Coll Ruiz and
it was a partier man he was he would
break Bilborough
crack Bubber up telling stories about
doing coke in the in the kitchen when he
was coming up as a chef and he had like
a spot in Jersey and then he had and
then he just opened a spot in the
Meatpacking District and he sent me a
message and it's one of its one of the
funniest things that anyone has ever
sent me okay and he goes you guys this
is what follows you when you are a food
celebrity human garbage pelicans and
it's just a picture of these two fat
women
we're birthday hats on and like you know
filter the kiddin birthday hats you see
if I wouldn't birthday I think it goes
this is who follows you and your food
celebrity human garbage pelicans it is
one of the funniest things I I laugh so
[ __ ] and I message guy and I said I
got to see you when I'm in New York we
get and he goes come to the restaurant
let's eat
I wanted him on the podcast I wanna he
there's a video that Opie just posted on
Twitter when they walk into his
apartment or a hotel I don't know it's
beautiful it's like in the middle of
Manhattan or whatever and he's just got
cash wads of cash laying on the table
and everybody starts going what the
hell's going on in here Ruiz just listen
because you know I'm a walking felony
the guy lived he was a vandalism I wish
he was still here I wish he lived
[ __ ] forever that guy was great but
it's like my friend's father passed away
who we loved this guy was great we used
to get you know get hammered all that
enough she's still going well
to get hammered I mean what has happened
we used to drink all the time and have
fun go out to dinner with this guy and
he passed away in his early 60s and and
the funeral was so sad cuz he was dead
but there was something about a funeral
and there are people out there that know
what I mean
they know what I mean right now and
they're looking at each other going [ __ ]
he's right and it's been a while since
we've been to one and it would be nice
you know a nice autumn day
whoo nice autumn day some nice hymnals
uh and I will raise you up on eagle's
wings raise you up above all this I
don't know the rest but that you know in
a nice church you go out in your black
suit maybe yeah maybe a bum a smoke
maybe you don't I don't know you know
that's all what you have to do and maybe
it's a sit-down restaurant or maybe
after would you do something at a bar
and you're just some wings in a couple
of cocktails my friend Michael's mother
I mean let me tell you right now what I
don't want anyone to die but the
meatballs I had at the after dinner I
would kill her myself
I would stretch they were so good soft
that's what meatball should be and I
don't listen she fought cancer very long
time the woman had more she was more of
a fighter tougher and she got more out
of life than I will ever get and any of
my clown friends will ever get out of
life by the way because she helped other
people and she had this camaraderie with
other people that were fighting this
thing and she raised money for people
and it was really amazing to look at
somebody's life was cut short but not in
in in [ __ ] substance at all she went
through hell but when you talk about
somebody who's a warrior champion I mean
I what's good about what I do is I spend
time with people who lead meaningless
lives utterly meaningless lives devoid
of honor devoid of anything people that
just float around
and you know but the food at this place
and I mean I'm talking about quesadillas
they had Italian they had wings it was
like a bar restaurant and I was sitting
down with a bunch of people I'd never
met I didn't know them and I felt I was
having one of the best times I've ever
had so here's I will throw this out I
don't want to I don't want this to seem
weird if you want me to go to a funeral
of someone you know I will go as long as
it does it you know as long as it
doesn't feel weird I like to I like to
hear about somebody's life you know
people say to me when I go to funerals
ago did you know this person well and
I'm like I don't need to know somebody
well to go and take stock of a life I
think it's a beautiful thing and I enjoy
it I don't know there are people out
here that say this is a sociopath
talking or I'm insane every episode
there's probably that reaction but
that's not the case here this is a
beautiful thing when someone is ripped
from us not when it's a young person
unless they're very young if they're
very very young it's fine because you
don't know you know what I mean if
they're very young it's fine again very
very young but if it's if it's in the
middle of their life 22 30s it's real
rough and what's 60 above again it's
it's it's fine so what I'm trying to say
and I've dug a little bit of a hole here
probably with certain people but I
people need to admit and my my
grandmother had a great funeral she was
like 89 and the priest went up and he
goes Dorothy and Ray comped the great
wreck accomplished sitting there most
people did that the the the mortician
thought the funeral was for him they
said well he looks fine well not fine it
looks better than most of the corpses
he's smoking for instance but my my
grandma the priest went up and he did
this Hellfire and brimstone speech goes
Dorothy has been preparing for this
moment for decades
decades shifting in our seats because we
were like [ __ ] whoa
basically he was laying it on the lot
priests and funerals that's their time
that's it I my grandfather's funeral
beautiful bagpipes bagpipes an Irish
funeral everybody bombed these are
beautiful thing much better than
weddings weddings suck uh what's the
other thing when the kids bore baptisms
and christenings [ __ ] off I love a good
funeral because you you really
appreciate life you appreciate being
alive when you drive out of or out of a
wake and you're sitting there and you're
you drive out of a burial it maybe it
was Holy Rood Cemetery in Hicksville and
you're sitting there at the stoplight
and a song comes on and it's a decent
song and you know the sun's out and you
drive in maybe you stopped at a 7-eleven
you get a Snapple and you just say to
yourself I'm [ __ ] here uh I would go
to one a month if I could so that I just
want to throw that out to people if you
want me at your funeral and I'd do the
whole thing but I do wake burial and
then whatever dinner is lunch or dinner
that we're doing I'd do the whole I do
the whole thing I do the wake and I come
back the next day for the burial and if
you tell me that the burial is only from
the family I come because I want to be
that I want to see it go into the ground
that's when it's poetic and meaningful
to me and listen it is what it is you
know I'm not I don't like death I like
funerals there are beautiful things
Long Island people have a couple of
cocktails they reconnect it's really and
there's a lot of lucky people right now
because so many people are dropping dead
on Long Island from heroin addiction and
there are so many lucky people that get
to go to these events all the time and
really kind of reconnect you know I'll
see you at the funeral that's what they
say